Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And I'm joined in the studio right now by one of our producers, Sean Cole. Hey there, Sean.
你好，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。此时此刻，我们的制作人之一肖恩·科尔也在演播室里。你好啊，肖恩。
Hello, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
So Sean, where do we start?
那么肖恩，我们从哪儿开始呢？
With Run the Jewels. Do you know Run the Jewels?
从Run the Jewels组合开始吧。你了解Run the Jewels吗？
Little bit.
了解一点。
They're so good. It's a rap group. It's two guys, really-- Killer Mike and El-P. And this is from their latest record.
他们非常棒。这是一个说唱组合，其实就是两个人——Killer Mike和El-P。这段音乐出自他们最新的唱片。
[MUSIC - "LEGEND HAS IT" BY RUN THE JEWELS]
[音乐 - Run the Jewels的《LEGEND HAS IT》]
Look like a man but I'm animal raw. We are the murderous pair that went to jail, and we murdered the murderers there.
外表像人，内心原始如野兽。我们是那对进了监狱的杀人狂，我们在那儿杀光了所有的杀人犯。
So one day, I was looking around for videos of them on YouTube. And there's a lot of videos of them being interviewed, and most of them are like this.
有一天，我在YouTube上搜他们的视频。关于他们的采访视频有很多，大多数都是这样的：
We make some [BLEEP] that's going to make you want to [BLEEP] tear the rafters out of the building.
我们创作了一些[哔——]音乐，会让你们想把[哔——]建筑的椽子都拆下来。
And then there's this one that's different. So just to say what we're looking at. They're sitting in a house together, quietly.
但有一个视频很特别。先描述一下我们看到的画面：他们正安静地坐在一间屋子里。
And we are Run the Jewels.
我们是Run the Jewels。
We are.
没错，是我们。
Looking directly into the web camera and answering the advice questions of teenage girls.
他们直视着网络摄像头，正在回答少女们提出的建议咨询。
This question is from Blue and she's 13 and from Seattle. She says, "I think I might be in love with one of my close friends. How do I know if I'm in love with him or just naive?" It's a good question.
这个问题来自布鲁，她13岁，来自西雅图。她说：“我觉得我可能爱上了我的一个好朋友。我怎么判断自己是真的爱上他了，还是仅仅因为太天真？”这是个好问题。
I'll be honest, Blue. To be in love, period, makes you feel kind of naive. You never know. There's no manual that says, hey, I'm in love, and I'm going to tell you--
老实说，布鲁。爱上一个人，这种感觉确实会让你觉得自己有点天真。你永远无法确定。没有什么说明书会告诉你，嘿，我恋爱了，而且我会告诉你——
It's 17 minutes long and I was spellbound. Within the first minute and a half, El-P realizes he's still wearing his sunglasses and takes them off all of the sudden out of politeness.
这段视频有17分钟长，我被深深吸引了。在开头的一分半钟里，El-P突然意识到自己还戴着墨镜，出于礼貌，他把它摘了下来。
But at about 12, 13 years old, you probably definitely have some of your first loves. I'm not going to say you aren't in love. I'm probably gonna say you probably are. But I'm probably going to warn you that, if you're in love, it's supposed to make you feel better and want to do better. It's not supposed to make you feel bad. So if any love starts to feel bad, definitely pull away from it.
但在12、13岁的时候，你肯定会有一些初恋的感觉。我不会说你没有恋爱。我可能会说你大概是恋爱了。但我还是要提醒你，如果恋爱了，它应该让你感觉更好，让你想变得更好。它不应该让你感到难受。所以，如果这段感情开始让你觉得难受，一定要及时抽身。
So this video was part of a series that was originally called "Ask a Grown Man," which is done by the online magazine Rookie, which is mainly aimed at teen and tween girls.
这个视频系列原名叫“请教成年人”（Ask a Grown Man），是由在线杂志《Rookie》制作的，主要面向十几岁的青少年女孩。
I have to say I know this series well. Full disclosure, my wife worked for Rookie a few years ago.
我得说我很熟悉这个系列。先披露一下，我妻子几年前曾为《Rookie》工作。
In the Run the Jewels video, all the questions are about love and relationships. This one girl, for example, she's 16 years old. Priscilla in Colorado Springs. She says she's never been in a relationship and never been kissed, in fact.
在Run the Jewels的视频里，所有的问题都关于爱和人际关系。比如这个女孩，她16岁，来自科罗拉多斯普林斯的普里西拉。她说她从未谈过恋爱，甚至连吻都没接过。
I'm worried that this means men aren't attracted to me and that I'll end up an old cat lady. That's pretty funny, Priscilla. You're already good because you're funny.
我担心这意味着男人对我没兴趣，我最后会变成那种孤独的老猫妇。普里西拉，这太搞笑了。你已经很棒了，因为你很幽默。
And so then she gets to her question, which is, should I tell whoever I end up kissing for the first time that I've never done this before? And Run the Jewels says, yeah, that's probably the best idea. And then Killer Mike says--
接着她问出了她的问题，那就是：我应该告诉第一次吻的人，我之前从没做过这件事吗？Run the Jewels回答说，是的，这大概是最好的主意。然后Killer Mike说——
I would be honored to be your first kiss.
能成为你的初吻对象，我深感荣幸。
And El-P just looks at him like, the hell?
而El-P看着他的表情就像在说，搞什么鬼？
If we were your age.
如果我们和你同龄的话。
Yeah, if we were your age. If you're lucky enough.
对，如果我们和你同龄。如果你足够幸运的话。
Should be specified. Yes.
应该说明一下。是的。
I mean, just seeing Run the Jewels do this-- or sometimes very famous TV people, Jimmy Fallon, or Paul Rudd. Ad-Rock does one from the Beastie Boys-- leaving their public persona and doing what is a very sincere thing, actually trying to be helpful to a kid that they don't know, in real time. There's almost never any edits to them.
我的意思是，看着Run the Jewels做这些——或者有时是像吉米·法伦或保罗·路德那样非常出名的电视名人。野兽男孩的Ad-Rock也参与过——他们放下公众形象，做着一件非常真诚的事情，实时地去帮助一个他们并不认识的孩子。视频几乎没有任何剪辑。
And then some of the questions are kind of hard and often, they come up with really good answers.
而且有些问题相当棘手，但他们通常都能给出非常好的建议。
And case in point. At the end of the Run the Jewels video, there's this one question which is just-- I think I would be nervous answering it.
举个例子。在Run the Jewels视频的最后，有一个问题简直是——我想如果是我，会很紧张去回答它。
So we're on the last one now.
我们要回答最后一个问题了。
Oh, no. This is a real one. Yeah, OK. Go for it.
噢，不。这可是个严肃的问题。好吧，来吧。
I've had a huge crush on an amazing guy for quite a while, but it's problematic because he's in his mid-20s. Makes me feel really special, but I think he has this effect on everyone. Do you have advice for a question on older people? And this is from G, who's 14 and in London.
我有很长一段时间一直暗恋着一个很棒的男生，但这很麻烦，因为他已经20多岁了。和他在一起让我觉得自己很特别，但我认为他对每个人都有这种影响。关于和比自己大很多的人交往，你们有什么建议吗？这个问题来自14岁的G，她在伦敦。
And then Mike sort of pauses for a second and then pointedly looks at the camera.
麦克停顿了一秒，然后目光直视镜头。
That's too big of an age gap. And that's not saying that you aren't capable of loving someone. That's not saying you won't love older people when you get older. But at 14 years old, your priorities and world perspective is not at the same place a person in their mid-20s is. You should always do things, for the next few years, that are age-appropriate. Between 14 and 18 years old--
那年龄差距太大了。这并不是说你没有能力去爱别人。这也不是说当你长大后不会爱上年长的人。但在14岁时，你的优先事项和世界观与20多岁的人不在同一个层面。在接下来的几年里，你应该做些符合年龄的事情。14岁到18岁之间——
And even then, Mike has the wherewithal to affirm how this girl feels.
即便如此，麦克还是有能力肯定这个女孩的感受。
I can't tell you your feelings for someone are wrong because feelings are just feelings. You can't control them. But if you or this person ever acted on those feelings, it'd put the person that you like behind bars. And it'd probably put you, emotionally, in a place that you don't deserve to be just because you haven't matured to the level that you're going to one day.
我不能说你对某人的感情是错的，因为感情就是感情。你无法控制它们。但如果你或这个人真的采取了行动，那会让他坐牢。这会让你在情感上处于一个你不该处于的位置，仅仅因为你还没有达到未来终将达到的成熟程度。
One thing that's interesting to think about, who else could this 14-year-old turn to for advice on this subject? I mean, I guess her friends, right? Though they're not going to know much more about this than she does.
值得思考的一点是，这个14岁的孩子还能向谁寻求建议呢？我想，应该是她的朋友吧？虽然他们了解的并不比她多。
And it's not something that you'd want to ask your parents, right? Like, hey, I'm in love with a 25-year-old. Is it OK if I date him? I mean, it's just like--
而且这事儿你也不想问父母，对吧？比如，嘿，我爱上了一个25岁的人。我可以和他约会吗？我的意思是，这就像——
Yeah. You know where's that's going to go.
没错。你知道结果会怎样。
It would go to, you're grounded for the next 13 years.
那肯定会被禁足13年。
This is a situation that needs somebody who's wiser than you are and sympathetic to you. It needs a grown-up. I think that's actually the best way to say it. It needs a grown-up. Somebody mature and thoughtful and nice.
这是一个需要比你更有智慧且能同情你的人来解决的情况。它需要一个成年人。我认为这是最好的说法。它需要一个成年人。一个成熟、体贴且友善的人。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, our program today is about situations like this one, where you need to step back from the chaos and drama of your troubles and feelings and call in somebody to get perspective-- situations where you call in an adult. We have all kinds of stories this hour, including an enemy of the people trying to make peace with some of the people. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ，我们今天的节目是关于这类情况的，你需要从问题的混乱和戏剧性中抽身，找人来提供一些视角——那些你需要召唤成年人来解决的情况。这一小时我们将讲述各种各样的故事，包括一个“人民公敌”试图与他的一些对手言和。请继续收听。
Act One, Are You There Ad-Rock? It's Me, Margaret.
第一幕：你在那儿吗，Ad-Rock？是我，玛格丽特。
So here are some of those videos where I'm beeping a couple words in this story here in the internet version of the show. There's a beeped version on our website if you prefer that. It's really interesting seeing the variety of questions and answers on the "Ask A Grown Man" series, partly because the drama the kids are going through is just interesting in and of itself, and partly, like we said, because you see the famous people in such a different light. Here's Sean again.
在互联网版本的节目里，我把这部分视频里的几个词消音了。如果你更喜欢有消音的版本，可以在我们的网站上找到。看到“请教成年人”系列中各种各样的问题和答案真的很有意思，一方面因为孩子们经历的那些戏剧性事件本身就很有趣，另一方面，正如我们所说，是因为你看到了名人们截然不同的一面。下面是肖恩。
You see them in a different light literally in some cases. They're usually on hazy laptop cameras. The sound is terrible. One morning, someone came into my office here at the show and thought I was Skyping with Seth Rogen.
在某些情况下，你确实能在字面上看到他们“不同”的一面。他们通常在模糊的笔记本摄像头前。声音效果很差。有一天早上，节目组里有人走进我办公室，以为我正在和塞斯·罗根视频通话。
Hi! Oop, there's someone behind me. There's people everywhere. There's a head right here--
嗨！噢，我后面有人。到处都是人。这里有个脑袋——
And this isn't the point of the series, but often you find yourself even more endeared to the guys in the videos. And one thing that comes up over and over is they're not sure they're worthy of the designation "grown man." Run the Jewels said as much.
虽然这不是这个系列的核心意义，但你常常会发现自己更加喜爱视频里的这些人。有一点在反复出现，那就是他们并不确定自己是否配得上“成年人”这个称号。Run the Jewels就说过。
Being grown is debatable.
到底算不算成年人还有待商榷。
And Stephen Colbert.
还有斯蒂芬·科尔伯特。
I'm honored to be considered a grown man.
被认为是成年人，我深感荣幸。
These two guys from Vampire Weekend.
这两个来自Vampire Weekend的家伙。
Ezra, do you feel like a grown man?
以斯拉，你觉得自己是成年人吗？
Not today. Not particularly.
今天不是。不太像。
And occasionally they don't say they're not grown up as much as just provide evidence to the fact.
有时他们不是说自己没长大，而是直接提供了证据。
Hi, I'm Hannibal Buress. This is "Ask a Grown Man." I just figured out how to use the Effects button, so I'm going to have this whole video in the Mirror effect and I don't care what you think about it. I got a s-- oh, no. Oh, man. I got two heads. Rahh!
嗨，我是汉尼拔·布列斯。这是“请教成年人”。我刚刚弄明白怎么用特效按钮，所以我要让整段视频都用镜像特效，不管你们怎么想。我有一个……噢，不。天哪。我有两个脑袋。吼！
I mean, look, we're dealing with comedians and musicians. They're not maybe the greatest grown men.
我的意思是，瞧，我们面对的是喜剧演员和音乐家。他们或许算不上最完美的成年人。
Tavi Gevinson is the creator and editor-in-chief of Rookie Mag. "Ask a Grown Man" was her idea, which is ironic because Tavi was pretty much a grown-up even when she was a kid. Rookie Mag grew out of her fashion blog, Style Rookie, which she founded when she was 11. And it got a huge amount of attention. Pretty soon she was being flown around the world to fashion shows, written about in the press.
塔薇·盖文森是《Rookie》杂志的创始人和主编。“请教成年人”是她的主意，这很讽刺，因为塔薇在还是个孩子的时候就基本像个大人了。《Rookie》杂志源于她的时尚博客“Style Rookie”，她11岁时创立了它。它获得了巨大的关注。很快她就被全世界的时尚秀邀请，媒体也开始报道她。
And then, after founding Rookie Mag at 15, she remembered this advice column she had read in her back issues of Sassy magazine called "Dear Boy." And she thought, why don't we do something like that? Though it isn't really a series she'd naturally gravitate toward herself.
在15岁创办《Rookie》杂志后，她想起了以前在旧版《Sassy》杂志里读过的建议专栏，叫“亲爱的男孩”。她想，我们为什么不也做点类似的事情呢？虽然这并不是她通常会自然而然参与的系列。
At least, when I was younger, I didn't really want advice from adults because I was so stubborn and defensive and was like, you could never possibly understand what I'm going through. But sometimes adults have really valuable advice. And if it's kind of presented to you by someone who you think is cool, you're like, OK, I'll take the good advice. There's something really special, too, about like-- I think in one of the Sassy columns, I think a girl wrote in about a guy who was mean to her and Thurston Moore was like, tell him I'm going to kick his ass.
至少，当我年轻的时候，我并不太想从成年人那里得到建议，因为我太固执、太自我防御了，我觉得你们根本不可能理解我正在经历什么。但有时成年人确实有非常有价值的建议。如果这些建议是由一个你觉得很酷的人呈现出来，你会想，好吧，我会接受这些建议。这里面还有些特别的东西——我想在《Sassy》的一篇专栏里，有个女孩写信问关于一个对她很刻薄的男孩，瑟斯顿·摩尔回答说，告诉他我要去揍他一顿。
Thurston more from Sonic Youth.
音速青春乐队的瑟斯顿·摩尔。
And it's like, if someone who you think is really cool says like, I'm on your team, that stays with you.
这就好像，如果你觉得很酷的人说，我是你这边的，那这种感觉会伴随你很久。
Rookie's posted more than 50 of these videos now, and not all of them with men. There's also "Ask a Grown Woman," which many times is aimed at queer readers. So there are videos from entertainers like Tig Notaro, Cameron Esposito, Tegan and Sara, and some straight women, too. These days, they just refer to the series as "Ask a Grown."
《Rookie》现在已经发布了50多个这样的视频，并不全是男人。还有“请教成年女性”，很多时候也是针对酷儿读者的。所以有很多来自像泰格·诺塔洛、卡梅隆·埃斯波西托、泰根与莎拉这样的艺人，也有一些异性恋女性的视频。如今，他们直接把这个系列称为“请教成年人”。
But the thing about the grown men videos is that you've got these much older celebrities who suddenly, magically become proxies for teen boys-- the sullen, awkward often confusing boys that Rookie readers are dealing with at school every day. Every grown-up answers four or five questions, give or take, sent in ahead of time. And a good number of them boil down to some version of, so he said this and I said this, and he said this and did this, and I said this and he did this. Does he like me?
但这些成年男性视频的特别之处在于，你拥有这些年龄大得多的名人们，他们突然神奇地成为了十几岁男孩的代理人——那些《Rookie》读者在学校里每天都要面对的阴郁、笨拙、常常令人困惑的男孩。每个成年人会回答四五个问题，多多少少，都是提前发来的。很大一部分可以归结为：他说了这个，我说了那个，他说了那个，做了这个，我说了这个，他又做了这个。他喜欢我吗？
Here's a question that was posed to Tunde Adebimpe from the band TV On the Radio.
这是一个提给TV On the Radio乐队的通德·阿德宾佩的问题。
My best friend made me a mixtape and about 99% of the songs on it are love songs. Is he trying to hint that he has feelings for me? Well, if he actually made you a cassette tape and played songs and recorded them onto an actual, physical cassette tape, then he's absolutely and completely in love with you because, who does that?
我最好的朋友给我做了一张混音带，里面99%的歌都是情歌。他在暗示他对我有感觉吗？好吧，如果他真的做了一盘磁带，把歌录进去，做成了实实在在的物理磁带，那他绝对完全地爱上了你，因为，谁会做那种事呢？
So that's an easy answer. But some of "the does he like me?" questions are harder-- occasionally in a zen koan-ish kind of way.
这算是一个简单的答案。但有些“他喜欢我吗”的问题更难回答——有时甚至带着一种禅宗公案般的色彩。
Does the amount of kisses on the end of a text show how much a guy likes you?
短信末尾的亲吻符号数量能显示一个男生有多喜欢你吗？
This is BJ Novak from The Office and a bunch of other stuff.
这是来自《办公室》和其他作品的BJ·诺瓦克。
I've been texting a boy I like for about three months and he sends five to seven kisses even though I always send four. OK. If you've been texting for about three months and you still have no idea how either of you feels about the other, that is a sign that texting is not telling you very much information. If three months go by, six months go by, a year goes by and you're still wondering what the other person thinks, it does show you that maybe you can inch towards more direct communication, even if it's over text.
我和一个我喜欢的男孩发短信发了大概三个月，他总是发五到七个亲吻符号，尽管我总是发四个。好吧。如果你们已经发了三个月的短信，却依然不知道彼此的感觉，那这就说明短信并没有传达太多信息。如果三个月、六个月，甚至一年过去了，你还在猜对方在想什么，这说明你可能需要向更直接的沟通迈进一步，即便只是通过短信。
So your actual question, five to seven kisses; you always send four. Who knows? Sometimes people overcompensate. So if he doesn't like you that way, maybe he's trying to be very affectionate to balance things out. Always think of the opposite reason that a thing can be happening, because often that's how humans work.
所以回到你的问题，五到七个吻；你总是发四个。谁知道呢？有时人们会补偿过度。所以如果他不是以那种方式喜欢你，也许他只是在努力表现得非常亲昵来平衡一切。总是试着从相反的角度思考一件事可能发生的原因，因为人类通常就是这样运作的。
I feel like this is when the series works best-- when it acts as a kind of handbook for human behavior handed from an adult to a kid. The idea that sometimes people behave in the opposite way from what they're feeling-- when you're a grown-up, that seems like something you always knew. But of course there was a time when you didn't, when just being alive every day felt like being in a country where you didn't speak the language, especially regarding the opposite sex.
我觉得这就是这个系列最有效的时候——当它充当了从成年人手中交给孩子的一本人类行为手册。那种有时人们表现出的行为与他们感受到的恰恰相反的观点——当你是个成年人时，这似乎是你一直都知道的事情。但当然，曾几何时你并不知道，当每天活着都感觉像是置身于一个你不说那种语言的国家，尤其是在对待异性方面。
I feel crazy saying this--
说这话我觉得自己像疯了——
Again, Tavi Gevinson.
再次引用塔薇·盖文森。
--because I'm like, oh my god, why does it sound like I grew up in a box where I wasn't allowed to ever have contact with another boy or something? But I really do think, if I think really hard back to middle school and high school, even--
——因为我心想，天哪，为什么听起来我好像是在一个盒子里长大的，在那儿我不被允许和任何其他男孩接触似的？但我真的认为，如果我回想中学和高中——
High school which, for Tavi, was about three years ago.
高中，对于塔薇来说，大约是三年前的事。
--it did feel like I needed a translator for what those guys were thinking. Like, a girl's like, why is this guy teasing me? And an adult man will be like, because he likes you. And a guy her own age will be like, because you're stupid. Because it makes sense.
——感觉确实像我需要一个翻译来理解那些男生在想什么。比如，一个女孩会问，为什么那个男孩总是逗我？而一个成年男性会说，因为他喜欢你。而一个和她同龄的男孩会说，因为你很蠢。这听起来更有道理。
Apart from that "does he like me?" line of questioning, you can organize most of the other love-related questions into just a handful of subcategories. There are a bunch of questions about kissing. Do you think it's possible to kiss someone and remain just friends? How do you go about kissing someone for the first time, anyway? Still a good question. And there's the subcategory of, how do I meet people that I find attractive? And sub-subcategory, once I do, what's my move?
除了“他喜欢我吗”这类问题，你可以把其他大多数关于爱的提问归入几个子类别中。有很多关于接吻的问题。你觉得有可能和某人接吻后还仅仅做朋友吗？无论如何，你该如何进行初吻呢？这仍然是个好问题。还有“如何遇见我感兴趣的人”这一类别。以及子类别：一旦遇见了，我该采取什么行动？
How do you flirt with a really shy boy?
你该如何调戏一个非常害羞的男生？
This is Jimmy Fallon.
这是吉米·法伦。
Perfect person to ask. I've flirted with so many shy boys growing up. Don't be too aggressive. Maybe he's shy because he thinks that you're going to hurt him in the end or you're going to embarrass him in front of his friends or something.
问这个人就对了。我在成长过程中调戏过太多害羞的男生了。别太有侵略性。也许他害羞是因为他认为你最终会伤害他，或者会在他朋友面前让他尴尬之类的。
Then there's the troubling subcategory of, I feel like I'm too short/tall/fat/unattractive in some way. How will I get boys to like me? And of course, all the grown men are reassuring and say attractiveness is subjective.
还有令人困扰的子类别：我觉得自己太矮/太高/太胖/在某方面没有吸引力。我怎么能让男生喜欢我？当然，所有的成年男性都会给出安慰，说吸引力是主观的。
Wildly subjective.
非常主观。
You're beautiful the way you are.
你本来的样子就很美。
I think everybody's beautiful.
我觉得每个人都很美。
All the things you'd expect them to say. But then there's this one moment in the video with Thom Yorke and Nigel Godrich of Radiohead that is really the platonic version of the answer you would want.
所有你预料中他们会说的话。但后来在电台司令乐队的汤姆·约克和尼格尔·古德里奇的视频中有一个时刻，那简直是你想要的关于这个问题的柏拉图式的完美答案。
A girl asks about a scar she has in the middle of her chest. She had surgery. And she says, I'm afraid that no one will find me attractive and they'll think it's ugly. And Thom Yorke points out one of his eyes.
一个女孩问起她胸口中间的一道疤痕。她做过手术。她说，我担心没有人会觉得我有吸引力，他们会觉得这很丑。汤姆·约克指了指他的一只眼睛。
This doesn't work properly. When I was born, I had several operations because I was born with this one completely shut. And now it sort of opens, but when I do this, I can't-- so. It's wonky. It doesn't work the same way. When I was your age, I was convinced that girls would think that was really not very nice at all.
这只眼睛不能正常工作。我出生时动了几次手术，因为我生来这只眼睛就是完全闭合的。现在它能张开了，但当我这样做时，我不能——所以，它是歪的。它工作方式不一样。当你这么大的时候，我确信女孩们会认为这很不讨喜。
That's all right.
没关系的。
That's fine. And I worked in this pub and this old woman, she was so funny. She used to come in all the time. She was the first person who really said to me, it's the nicest thing about you. So you'd be surprised.
那挺好。我曾在酒吧工作，有个老太太，她非常风趣。她总是来。她是第一个真正对我说，这是你身上最好看的东西的人。所以你会感到惊讶的。
She was a sage. She spoke the truth.
她是一位智者。她说了真话。
She did, actually.
确实是。
A bit.
有点。
So everyone is imperfect. No one has a symmetrical face. No one's body is perfect. Don't worry.
所以每个人都不完美。没有人有对称的脸。没有人的身体是完美的。别担心。
Not all of the grown men do this good a job. Tavi told me every now and they've had to edit out someone saying, eh, none of this will matter in a couple of years. You're just a kid. What do you know? And then occasionally the guys just don't know what to say, or they say something kind of questionable.
并非所有成年人都能做得这么好。塔薇告诉我，偶尔他们不得不剪掉一些人说的话，比如，“呃，几年后这一切都没什么意义了。你只是个孩子。你知道什么？”有时这些人就是不知道该说什么，或者说了些颇有争议的话。
Ruby from England wrote in to ask why porn is so degrading to women and Seth Rogen said, well, a lot of it is degrading to women.
英国的鲁比写信询问为什么色情片对女性如此贬低，塞斯·罗根说，好吧，大部分确实对女性很贬低。
But I think there's a lot of pornography that I would say is on the more romantic side of things on the grand scale of pornography. If what you're looking for is that, I would suggest browsing the female-friendly categories of the free porn websites on the internet. Female-friendly.
但我认为在色情制品的宏大尺度上，也有很多我认为属于更浪漫一边的内容。如果你在寻找那类内容，我建议浏览互联网上免费色情网站中对女性友好的类别。女性友好。
Yeah, I would say that's not a good answer.
是啊，我会说这不是一个好答案。
Probably the most confident question answerers are the dads, like Killer Mike from Run the Jewels. Also Judd Apatow, Terry Crews, Stephen Colbert. This question clearly pushed a couple of buttons for Colbert.
大概最有信心的回答者是那些父亲们，比如Run the Jewels的Killer Mike。还有贾德·阿帕图、泰瑞·克鲁斯、斯蒂芬·科尔伯特。这个问题明显触动了科尔伯特的某些神经。
My dad won't let me sleep at my boyfriend's house and there is no real reason for that. I assume it's because he's very close-minded about sex, but when I try to discuss it with him he gets very angry and refuses to talk about it. I've been with my boyfriend for a year and my whole family approves of him. What do you think is the best way to talk to a dad like this to convince him to let me sleep at my boyfriend's house? Eve, age 19.
我爸爸不让我住在男朋友家里，而且没有真正的理由。我假设是因为他对性非常封闭，但当我尝试和他讨论时，他会变得非常生气并拒绝谈论。我和男朋友在一起一年了，我的整个家庭都很认可他。关于年长的人，你有什么建议吗？这个问题来自19岁的伊芙。
Eve, I'm going to disappoint you here. He might have his own reasons, so give your father that much credit. I don't know your dad. I don't know what his reasons are. One reason could be that, while he may not actually be close-minded about sex-- after all, you exist, so he's fairly open-minded about it-- but he may think that sex and a relationship aren't the same thing. And he might be someone who's traditional and wants you to be married or even be older before he is comfortable with you having a physical relationship with a boy or a girl.
伊芙，我得让你失望了。他可能有自己的理由，所以请给你的父亲多一些信任。我不认识你父亲。我不知道他的理由是什么。一个原因可能是，虽然他在性方面并不一定是封闭的——毕竟，你都存在了，所以他对此还是相当开明的——但他可能认为性和恋爱不是一回事。他可能是一个传统的人，希望你在结婚或者再大一点之前，对于和一个男生或女生有身体关系感到自在。
When you try to discuss it with him, he gets very angry and refuses to talk about it. Well, I mean, maybe he's embarrassed to talk about sex with his daughter because it's a very intimate thing. And that's not unusual. Your dad's not off the reservation here. And I realize I just made a reference to reservations, which is probably insensitive to Native Americans. OK.
当你尝试和他讨论时，他变得非常生气并拒绝谈论。好吧，我的意思是，也许他因为和女儿谈论性而感到尴尬，因为这是一件非常私密的事情。这并不罕见。你爸爸在这里并没有过分。我知道我刚刚提到了“保留地”，这可能对美洲原住民不敏感。好吧。
Yeah, I do think the best ones are when they are dads, so their angle is more paternal.
是啊，我确实认为当他们是父亲时，效果是最好的，因为他们的角度更像父亲。
Well, it's like, these girls are like almost proxies. The same way that the men are like proxies for the boys that they're having to deal with, these girls are like proxies for their daughters practically.
就像是，这些女孩几乎是代理人。就像这些男人是他们不得不面对的男孩的代理人一样，这些女孩实际上就像是他们的女儿。
Ugh. Yeah. No, you're right. It made it all sound really creepy, but you're right.
呃。是啊。不，你是对的。这话听起来很令人毛骨悚然，但你是对的。
And then there's what might be the most moving moment in the "Ask a Grown" videos, which isn't from one of the guys, nor is it about boy trouble. And it also makes you realize that the distance between what the teens are going through and what the grown-ups are going through isn't always so vast.
还有“请教成年人”视频中最令人感动的时刻，它不是来自其中任何一个男人，也不是关于恋爱烦恼。它也让你意识到，青少年经历的事情与成年人经历的事情之间的距离并不总是那么遥远。
This girl wrote in and said, my mom recently passed away and I feel like I cannot imagine someone ever loving me as much as she did, and now I've lost that.
这个女孩写信说，我妈妈最近去世了，我觉得我无法想象有人会像她那样爱我，现在我失去了那种爱。
I keep wondering, when someone dies, where does that love go? I just feel completely alone and unloved, which is horrible because I used to be reminded every day that someone loves me.
我一直想知道，当人去世后，那份爱去了哪里？我感到完全孤独且没人爱，这太糟糕了，因为我过去每天都被提醒有人爱着我。
And Tig Notaro has-- a lot of her work has been about coping with her mom's death and so we sent her that question as some of the ones she could choose from.
泰格·诺塔洛有很多作品是关于如何应对她母亲的去世，所以我们把那个问题作为她可以选择的问题之一发给了她。
Everything seems pointless because the only person who had real love for me is gone and I didn't make the most of it when I could. Is there any way to come to terms with that? Signed, The Letter C.
一切似乎都毫无意义，因为唯一真正爱我的人已经走了，而且我本可以在她活着时多陪陪她的。有什么方法可以接受这一点吗？签名：C。
The Letter C, first of all, I am very sorry about your mother. As far as your mother being the only person that truly loved you, I'm certain other people in your life love you tremendously and that's where the love can go. And a really great gift to give your mother is to truly spend time with good people around you and cherish the time you have with them and appreciate who they are and what they are in your life. That's a really great gift to you, your mother, and other people.
C，首先，对于你的母亲，我深感遗憾。至于说你的母亲是唯一真正爱你的人，我相信你生命中其他人也极其爱你，这就是爱可以去的地方。给你的母亲一份真正伟大的礼物，就是花时间陪伴你身边的好人，珍惜与他们在一起的时光，欣赏他们是谁，他们在你生命中意味着什么。这对你、你的母亲和其他人来说，是一份非常伟大的礼物。
So being present and aware of your time with people-- that's really where the love can go. That's what I'm doing, and it's helpful. I hope this has been helpful.
所以，活在当下并珍惜与人们在一起的时间——那正是爱可以去的地方。我就是这么做的，这很有帮助。我希望这对你有帮助。
Thankfully, the girl who asked that question actually found Tig's video and watched it and she commented on the website. If you go to the page, you can read it. She said, in part, "I sent that question to Rookie about my mother a few months ago. I eagerly, and perhaps naively, clicked upon every "Ask" article that appeared expecting an answer or just an indication that I had been heard. After a bit, my enthusiasm began to wane as my question wasn't featured. I completely forgot about it, in fact, until this video. I am now shaking and crying. The mere fact that someone has replied is amazing, but the enormous deal that Tig Notaro has answered is fucking mind-blowing.
谢天谢地，那个提问的女孩真的找到了泰格的视频并看了它，她在网站上发表了评论。如果你去那个页面，你可以读到它。她写道，部分内容如下：“几个月前，我发了那个关于我母亲的问题给《Rookie》。我热切地，也许有点天真地点击了每一个出现的‘请教’文章，期待着一个回答或者仅仅是一个我被听到的信号。过了一会儿，我的热情开始消退，因为我的问题没有被选中。事实上，我完全忘了它，直到这个视频出现。我现在浑身发抖，哭个不停。有人回复了这一事实本身就令人惊讶，而泰格·诺塔洛亲自回答了这一事实简直是太令人震撼了。”
I have been through so much shit and been stuck in this tiny bubble of despair and self-hatred, feeling so small and weak, and the fact that someone cares is crazy and has kind of taken me out of that. So I would just like to say a major thank you from the bottom of my heart. You have no idea how much you have helped me.
“我经历了太多的糟糕事，被困在这个绝望和自我厌恶的微小泡泡里，感到自己如此渺小和脆弱，而有人关心这一事实太疯狂了，它在某种程度上把我从那种状态中拉了出来。所以，我想从内心深处表达最诚挚的感谢。你不知道你给了我多大的帮助。”
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program. Rookie is starting a podcast next month. If you have a teenage girl in your life, or you are a teenage girl, I have to say Rookie is amazing. rookiemag.com. The other "Ask a Grown" videos are there.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。《Rookie》下个月要开始做播客了。如果你的生活中有一个十几岁的女孩，或者你本人就是，我必须说《Rookie》真是太棒了。rookiemag.com。其他的“请教成年人”视频都在那里。
I made one, by the way, years ago. It was explained to me that I wasn't so well-known to the teenage readers and could I make animal balloons to keep the interest level up. So that's there.
顺便提一下，几年前我也做过一个。当时有人告诉我，我对于青少年读者来说没那么出名，能不能做个气球动物来维持兴趣水平。所以那个视频也在那儿。
Act Two, Enemy of the People vs. The People.
第二幕：人民公敌与人民。
It's a sign of adulthood that you're actually a functioning normal adult to find yourself asking questions like, what am I doing wrong? Why are you so upset with me? Small children do not ask these questions. These questions are for adults. They're hard, and often you're not going to like the answers. In this next story, a grown-up turns to other grown-ups with just these questions. Here's David Kestenbaum.
一个成熟的人，一个功能正常的成年人的标志就是发现自己会问诸如：我做错了什么？为什么你对我这么生气？小孩子是不会问这些问题的。这些问题属于成年人。它们很难，而且通常你不会喜欢答案。在接下来的故事中，一个成年人转向其他成年人提出了这些问题。这里是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Mike Wilson is the editor of the Dallas Morning News, the newspaper, and about six months ago, he started to make a pretty serious effort to try to talk to the people who hate his guts. They were easy to find. Right outside his window holding signs.
迈克·威尔逊是《达拉斯晨报》的编辑，大约六个月前，他开始非常认真地尝试与那些恨他入骨的人谈话。他们很容易找到。就在他窗外举着牌子。
They said things like, boycott Dallas Morning News, sort of chanting, and obviously upset with us.
他们喊着像“抵制达拉斯晨报”这样的话，一直在喊口号，显然对我们非常不满。
Had that ever happened before?
以前发生过这种事吗？
Oh, no. No.
哦，没有。从来没有。
The protesters were angry at the paper because the editorial board had just endorsed Hillary Clinton, which was the first time the paper had endorsed a Democrat for president in, oh, quite a while.
抗议者对这份报纸很愤怒，因为编辑部刚刚宣布支持希拉里·克林顿，这是该报在很长一段时间内首次支持民主党总统候选人。
Yes. It was at least since the Roosevelt administration.
是的。至少从罗斯福政府以来就没有过。
Like 75 years or something.
比如75年还是多少年。
Yes.
是的。
Some papers, the readers are largely Democrat or largely Republican. But the Dallas Morning News, there's a split in a pretty serious way. Readers in Dallas tend to be Democrats, but the surrounding region is very red, very conservative. And apparently, now pretty angry with the newspaper.
有些报纸的读者主要是民主党人或共和党人。但《达拉斯晨报》的情况是严重的立场分歧。达拉斯的读者往往是民主党人，但周边地区非常保守，非常红。显然，现在他们对抗报纸非常愤怒。
So I went and got on the elevator and walked out there and introduced myself. And I was curious. I wanted to know what would they say about what we'd written, and would they be interested in hearing any of my point of view about it?
所以我走上电梯，走到外面，做了自我介绍。我很好奇。我想知道他们对我们写的文章有什么看法，他们是否有兴趣听听我关于这方面的观点？
The answer? Sort of. He walked up to the crowd, introduced himself, said he was the editor of the paper. There was shouting, then talking. It was civil. It ended with selfies with the editor. Then Mike came back inside, and they kept protesting.
答案？算是有吧。他走到人群中，介绍了自己，说是报社的编辑。有叫喊声，然后是交谈。很文明。最后以与编辑的自拍告终。然后迈克回到室内，他们继续抗议。
Things didn't get any better after the election. In fact, Mike began to worry that some readers were losing faith in the paper. They weren't just upset with the editorial stance. They were upset with the day-to-day journalism. Around this time, President Trump was tweeting things like, "the fake news media is going crazy with their conspiracy theories and blind hatred." And he called the media the enemy of the people.
选举后情况并没有好转。事实上，迈克开始担心一些读者正在对报纸失去信心。他们不仅仅是对编辑立场不满，他们对日常新闻报道也不满。大约在那个时候，特朗普总统发推文说，“假新闻媒体正在疯狂地散布阴谋论和盲目的仇恨。”他还把媒体称为人民公敌。
So in response, Mike wrote a column, which was lighthearted in parts but also pointed. Quote, "in my job, I oversee about 250 enemies of the people. We have enemies of the people who make maps, cover high school baseball, send tweets about the Cowboys, assign book reviews, critique restaurants, track North Texas home prices, and write profiles of tech entrepreneurs. One enemy of the people spends his days talking to grieving families and carefully crafting stories of the dead." Email responses poured in, like this one.
作为回应，迈克写了一篇专栏，其中部分内容轻松但很有针对性。引用：“在我的工作中，我监督着大约250名‘人民公敌’。我们有负责制作地图的‘人民公敌’，有报道高中棒球的，有发送牛仔队推文的，有分配书评的，有评论餐馆的，有追踪北德克萨斯房价的，还有撰写科技企业家侧写的。其中一名‘人民公敌’整天与悲伤的家庭交谈，并小心翼翼地撰写死者的故事。”邮件回复涌入，比如这一条：
"Please pass the tissue so I can wipe away the tears for the media. President Trump was obviously specifically referring to the political reporting from the mainstream media regarding his presidency. His comment may have been overbroad, but here is the point. The mainstream media, including the Dallas Morning News, are the propaganda arm of the Democratic Party."
“请把纸巾递给我，让我擦去为媒体流下的眼泪。特朗普总统显然特指主流媒体对其总统任期的政治报道。他的评论可能太笼统了，但重点是。包括《达拉斯晨报》在内的主流媒体，是民主党的宣传机构。”
There were positive ones, too, but it was a punishing experience reading the emails that morning. And Mike didn't want to just ignore the bad ones. So he decided to write back to that guy.
当然也有积极的邮件，但那天早上阅读那些邮件是一次痛苦的经历。迈克不想直接无视那些差评。所以他决定回信给那个家伙。
I saw it as kind of an invitation.
我把它看作是一种邀请。
It's a bit of an angry invitation.
这有点像是愤怒的邀请。
Yeah. He might not have meant it as an invitation, but I tried to take it as one.
是啊。他可能不是那个意思，但我试着把它当成邀请。
So Mike-- who, remember, is the editor of the paper; he's got meetings and stuff going on all day long-- he starts corresponding with a bunch of the people who'd written in with kind of limited success.
所以迈克——记住，他是报纸编辑；他整天都有会议和各种事务——他开始与一群发邮件的人沟通，但成果有限。
I'm having a lot of conversations with readers where they say, you're not fair. And I say, am too. And they say, are not. And I feel like that's kind of not working.
我正和许多读者谈话，他们说，你们不公平。我说，我公平。他们说，不公平。我觉得这行不通。
And here, Mike does this thing that just seems so rare in situations where people do not agree about something. He invites the other side to come in and talk face to face. I love this as a strategy for healing the divides of our nation. I just don't know how well it works.
在这里，迈克做了一件在人们意见不合的情况下极其罕见的事情。他邀请对方当面谈谈。我喜欢这个化解国家分歧的策略。只是我不知道效果如何。
The first person he asked said no, but the guy who wrote the "please pass the tissue" email agreed to come in. And so did this other reader who was so upset when the paper sent him a renewal notice that he'd thrown it in the trash. Mike wanted these guys to understand more about the newspaper they were so angry with. He wanted them to sit in on an editorial meeting where the senior staff discusses what goes on the front page. But also he wanted to understand more about them. He wanted to know who they were, not just as angry emailers. As people.
他邀请的第一个人拒绝了，但写了那封“请递给我纸巾”邮件的家伙同意过来。还有另一位读者也同意了，他在报纸寄来续订通知时非常生气，直接把它扔进了垃圾桶。迈克想让这些人更了解他们如此愤怒的报纸。他想让他们旁听编辑部会议，高级职员在那里讨论头版放什么。但也想更了解他们。他想知道他们是谁，不仅仅是愤怒的邮件发送者。而是作为人。
I wanted to know, too, so I went to visit them before they came in. It turns out the two people Mike invited in, they do not think the Dallas Morning News is the enemy of the people. They love the paper. Or they used to. The guy who wrote saying he was thinking of giving up his subscription is also named Mike. Mike Standish. He's 60 years old. Businessman. Blunt, but tries to be polite. Uses the word stupid, then apologizes for it. I asked him how long he'd been reading the paper.
我也想知道，所以我去拜访了他们。结果发现，迈克邀请来的两个人并不认为《达拉斯晨报》是人民公敌。他们爱这份报纸。或者说，他们曾经爱过。那个说打算放弃订阅的家伙也叫迈克。迈克·斯坦迪什。他60岁。商人。直率，但尽量保持礼貌。用了“愚蠢”这个词，然后为此道歉。我问他订阅这份报纸多久了。
Oh, gosh. Since I was young. I mean, I remember when the Dallas Morning News didn't show up at 5:30 in the morning, I would literally sit out in a lawn chair, eating my Wheaties, waiting for the guy to show up and then giving him a hard time when he was late.
噢，天哪。从我年轻时起。我的意思是，我记得当《达拉斯晨报》没有在早晨5:30送达时，我会坐在草坪椅上吃着麦片，等着送报人出现，然后在他迟到时给他点颜色看看。
Before that, when he was a boy, he told me he used to throw the paper, meaning deliver it on his Stingray bicycle, bag stuffed with giant Sunday papers, tossing them at house after house.
在这之前，还是个男孩的时候，他告诉我他曾经负责送报，意味着骑着他的Stingray自行车，袋子里塞满了巨大的周日刊，挨家挨户地投递。
The other man is a doctor. His name is Stace Bradshaw, and he is also the kind of reader newspaper editors dream of. He gets the actual, physical newspaper delivered. Reads it after he's walked the dog, before he gets his daughter up for school. Though these days, the newspaper's kind of been driving him nuts. He finds himself writing notes in the margins in pen and also writing that "please pass the tissue" email.
另一位先生是位医生。他叫斯塔斯·布拉德肖，他也是报纸编辑梦寐以求的那种读者。他订的是实体的纸质报纸。遛完狗后读，在叫醒女儿上学前读。不过最近，这份报纸让他很抓狂。他发现自己会在边栏用笔写下注释，还会写出那封“请把纸巾递给我”的邮件。
I admit I was a little snarky at first because I guess I was a little upset.
我承认起初我有点刻薄，因为我想我当时有点生气。
It felt good to write, though.
不过写出来感觉真好。
It was a catharsis. It was cathartic to write it and hit send. And I thought it would just go off into the ether and I would never hear anything back from him, but at least I felt good about it. And then when I got a response back--
这是一种宣泄。写出来并点击发送是宣泄性的。我以为它会消失在以太中，我也永远不会收到回音，但至少我感觉很好。然后当我收到回信时——
How long?
过了多久？
Let's see. What's the time on this? I think I sent it at 9:31, and the first response I got back was at 9:49. So literally 18 minutes later, I got a response. And then we exchanged several emails back and forth. And I was very impressed with that, that the editor would take the time to respond back to me.
我看看。这个时间是多久？我想我是在9:31发送的，我收到的第一次回复是在9:49。所以字面上看，18分钟后，我收到了回应。然后我们来回交换了几封邮件。我对此印象非常深刻，编辑竟然会花时间回复我。
Stace and Mike told me they are fine with stories that are tough on Trump. They just feel like the mainstream media coverage of things feels skewed these days. There are stories about protests against the pipeline, but not so many about the argument for the pipeline, or on education.
斯塔斯和迈克告诉我，对于批评特朗普的报道他们没问题。他们只是觉得现在主流媒体对事情的报道显得有所偏颇。有很多关于抗议输油管道的报道，但关于支持管道的论点的报道却不多，或者关于教育的报道也是如此。
Mike Standish showed me a recent edition of the Dallas Morning News. The lead story on the opinion section was headlined "Public School Saved My Special Needs Kid." There was a colorful illustration of a little girl with giant butterfly wings. There was an opposing piece below making a school choice argument, but the headline was a lot smaller.
迈克·斯坦迪什给我展示了《达拉斯晨报》最近的一期。观点版的头条是“公立学校拯救了我残疾的孩子”。有一个小女孩长着巨大蝴蝶翅膀的彩色插图。下面有另一篇辩论择校权的文章，但标题小得多。
Mike and Stace say, as a whole, the newspaper just feels like it's coming from a particular mindset. They feel like it's put together by liberals who are trying not to be biased but they just have this blind spot, like they have a hard time seeing how the stuff they write can come across to conservatives.
迈克和斯塔斯说，总体而言，报纸给人的感觉就是有一种特定的心态。他们觉得这是由自由派拼凑出来的，他们试图不带偏见，但他们就是有这种盲点，比如他们很难看到自己写的东西在保守派看来会是什么样子。
Just before 3 o'clock last Tuesday afternoon, Stace and Mike both arrived at the Dallas Morning News building. And just a quick note about the building. The entire middle section, the main architectural feature, is what looks like an enormous stone tablet 3 stories high, with a quote on it from the newspaper's founder in giant letters. It's as if Moses had brought back a second, lesser-known set of commandments for journalists. We crane our necks back. Mike Standish reads the last line.
就在上周二下午3点前，斯塔斯和迈克都到达了《达拉斯晨报》大楼。关于这栋大楼，一个小细节。整个中间部分，主要的建筑特征是一块看起来像巨大的石板，三层楼高，上面刻着报社创始人的名言，字体巨大。就好像摩西带回了第二套鲜为人知的记者诫律。我们向后仰着脖子。迈克·斯坦迪什读了最后一行。
"Acknowledge the right of the people to get from the newspaper both sides of every important question." They need to circle that one. That last part. Uh-huh.
“承认人民有权从报纸获得每一个重要问题的两面观点。”他们需要圈出这一句。最后那部分。嗯哼。
Hey, I'm Mike.
嘿，我是迈克。
I'm Stace Bradshaw. Good to meet you.
我是斯塔斯·布拉德肖。很高兴见到你。
Hey, Doctor. Nice to meet you.
嘿，医生。很高兴见到你。
Mike Standish. Mike.
迈克·斯坦迪什。迈克。
Hey, Mike, nice to meet you, too. You guys want to come in for a few minutes?
嘿，迈克，很高兴见到你。你们想进来坐几分钟吗？
When they meet with Mike Wilson, the editor, everyone is on their best behavior. They immediately talk about the one part of the paper they all agree is truly excellent, the sports section.
当他们见到编辑迈克·威尔逊时，每个人都表现得非常有礼貌。他们立即谈到了报纸中他们一致认为真正卓越的部分：体育版。
Especially football season.
尤其是橄榄球赛季。
And then Mike Wilson leads the way to a conference room for the front page editors meeting. There are worn-out chairs, a long table, and about a dozen people. Everyone sits down and the meeting starts.
然后迈克·威尔逊带他们去会议室参加头版编辑会议。那儿有磨损的椅子、一张长桌和大约十几个人。大家坐下，会议开始。
Well, any thoughts on the paper today?
好了，对今天的报纸有什么看法？
I really appreciated the--
我非常欣赏那个——
The editors of the various sections go over the stories of the day and the ones they think could run on the front page. There is a story a reporter had uncovered about a secret executive retreat that Toyota was building up in the hills, complete with a private racetrack. They had aerial photos of it.
各版的编辑回顾当天的故事，以及他们认为可以登上头版的内容。有个记者揭露了一个丰田正在山上建设的秘密行政度假村，里面还有一个私人赛道。他们有航拍照片。
There was a story about the fire and police pension fund. One about a theater director who had been shot through the mouth but was returning to the stage. Wire stories about the WikiLeaks CIA document and the Republican health care bill. And then there was this one.
还有一个关于消防和警察养老基金的故事。一个关于一位口部中枪但重返舞台的剧院导演的故事。关于维基解密中情局文件和共和党医保法案的电讯稿。然后就是这个。
Homeland Security Secretary John Kelly was in town today. We really didn't know what he was going to talk about. It was kind of an unannounced meeting as he was making a swing down toward the border. He talked about a lot of stuff that we couldn't use. But then he confirmed what he confirmed to CNN yesterday that the Department is looking at a plan to separate children from their parents at the border as a way to kind of deter refugees from trying to come into the US.
国土安全部长约翰·凯利今天在城里。我们真的不知道他会谈些什么。这是一个未经宣布的会议，他正向下往边境方向巡视。他谈了很多我们无法使用的内容。但随后他确认了昨天向CNN确认的事情，即国土安全部正在考虑一项计划，将儿童与父母在边境分离，作为一种威慑难民尝试进入美国的方式。
Essentially, it's kind of a plan that uses fear as a deterrent. So there's a bit of irony in it because a lot of the families that are coming up here obviously are trying to flee extreme violence. A little bit of fear is maybe not going to work with them.
本质上，这是一种利用恐惧作为威慑的计划。这里有点讽刺意味，因为很多来到这里的家庭显然是在逃离极端的暴力。一点点恐惧可能对他们没用。
I looked over, but I couldn't get a read on how this was all playing with the two visitors. The editors voted on what they thought should go on the front page. Mike would make the final decisions later. And the meeting broke up. I pulled Stace Bradshaw, the doctor, aside. He told me that story about how the US might start separating children from their parents at the border, he worried about how that might get portrayed in the paper.
我看了看，但我无法读出这两位访客对此有何想法。编辑们投票选出他们认为应该上头版的内容。迈克稍后会做最终决定。会议散了。我把医生斯塔斯·布拉德肖拉到一边。他告诉我那个关于美国可能在边境开始拆散儿童与父母的故事，他担心这在报纸上会被如何描绘。
I'm thinking there's got to be a lot more behind that. That sounds terrible. That sounds very nefarious and I find it hard to believe that that's really what it is. There's got to be something a lot more that's out there being misinterpreted. But I'm sitting there thinking, OK, I can see what kind of articles and what kind of headlines this is going to generate. And it's probably going to be with incomplete information and probably not fair.
我觉得那后面肯定还有很多东西。这听起来太糟糕了。听起来非常邪恶，我很难相信事实真的如此。肯定还有更多东西被曲解了。但我坐在那儿想，好吧，我能看出这会产生什么样的文章和什么样的标题。这很可能信息不全，而且很可能不公平。
But overall, he said the meaning seemed surprisingly boring. He meant that in a good way, like professional.
但总的来说，他说这次会议看起来出奇地无聊。他是指好的方面，比如专业。
I was just struck by how ordinary, matter of fact it was. You see that they don't have horns and they're not out to be sinister.
我只是被它那种平常、实事求是的程度所震撼。你看到他们并没有长角，也不是要搞什么阴谋。
Did you really think they were?
你真的以为他们有吗？
Well, again, I've had visions of them all sitting around the water cooler and ripping on Republicans and ripping on Trump. And also, it's good to talk to people one on one and realize that they don't even realize necessarily what you're thinking.
好吧，同样，我曾设想他们都坐在饮水机旁攻击共和党人和攻击特朗普。而且，一对一地与人交谈并意识到他们甚至不一定知道你在想什么，这感觉真好。
Stace went in to sit down with Mike Wilson, the editor, in his office. Two people trying to talk through this thing our country seems to be wrestling with. Is the mainstream media biased? They started with smaller stuff. Where are you from? Do you have kids? And then Mike Wilson brought up their email exchange.
斯塔斯进去和编辑迈克·威尔逊坐在办公室里交谈。两个人试图通过这件事来对话，而我们的国家似乎正在为之纠结。主流媒体有偏见吗？他们从琐事谈起。你是哪里人？你有孩子吗？然后迈克·威尔逊提起了他们的邮件交流。
So let me ask you about how our conversation began. I started. I wrote this article about defending my people against being called enemies of the people by the president. And I got a lot of letters about that. Yours struck me because you started with a pretty, I thought, funny line. "Please pass the tissues so I can wipe away the tears for the media."
那么让我问问我们谈话的起因。我开始了。我写了这篇文章捍卫我的人民不被总统称为人民公敌。我收到了很多关于那篇文章的信。你的信打动了我，因为你以一个相当好笑的句子开头：“请递给我纸巾，让我擦去为媒体流下的眼泪。”
I spoke to a lot of readers during the campaign who said something similar to what you're saying, where they felt like the coverage was slanted against Donald Trump. And one of the things that I used to say in response was, this is a very unconventional candidate who makes a lot of news. The nature of news is something you've never seen before. Something that's unprecedented. And so from his very early statements about the Mexicans coming over the border to the Access Hollywood video that made so much news--
我在竞选期间与许多读者交谈过，他们说的话和你说的类似，他们觉得报道对唐纳德·特朗普有偏见。我过去回应的一点是，这是一个非常非传统的候选人，制造了很多新闻。新闻的本质是你从未见过的事情。那是前所未有的事情。所以从他早期关于墨西哥人越境的声明，到制造了如此多新闻的《走进好莱坞》录像——
He sucks the oxygen out of the room. There's no question.
他吸干了屋子里的氧气。毫无疑问。
I was just wondering if you felt like-- he made so much news that it was impossible for us to not keep reporting it. But was it just that that you were reacting to? Or did you feel like, above and beyond that, we were after him?
我只是想知道你是否觉得——他制造了太多新闻，我们不可能不持续报道。但这仅仅是你反应的原因吗？还是你觉得，除此之外，我们还在针对他？
What I've identified to myself personally is what I look at, and I look at three types of bias. And one type of bias is what I call story selection bias. And a good example of that is there was a piece that was covering the stories and lives of illegal immigrants. And I thought those were good articles. There was a good piece. But then I'm thinking, I've lived here since 1995. I've never seen anyone select to do a story, an investigative report, on how does illegal immigration impact DISD-- Dallas Independent School District.
我个人认定的是我关注的东西，我看三种类型的偏见。一种偏见是我称之为报道选择偏见。一个很好的例子是一篇涵盖非法移民故事和生活文章。我认为那是好文章。那是一篇好文章。但我随后想，我自1995年以来一直住在这里。我从来没见过任何人选择做一个关于非法移民如何影响达拉斯独立学区的调查报道。
Mike, the editor, told me the paper has reported on this stuff. It comes up all the time in stories they do on the school system and how it's struggling to serve students. But he told me they hadn't done a separate article about the economic effects of illegal immigration. And he said it sounded like a fine idea.
编辑迈克告诉我，报纸确实报道过这些。这在他们关于学校系统及其实力如何挣扎着服务学生的报道中经常出现。但他告诉我，他们还没有做过一篇关于非法移民经济影响的单独文章。他说听起来是个好主意。
Stace brought up another kind of bias he sees, which is just the choice of headlines and the particular wording used in the story. He'd brought in the newspaper from the day after Trump had given his big speech to Congress. Stace had circled parts in pen and written notes next to this one news analysis story. Headline, "A Challenge to Think Big, with Few Details."
斯塔斯提出了他看到的另一种偏见，那就是标题的选择和报道中使用的特定措辞。他带来了特朗普在国会发表大演讲后的那张报纸。斯塔斯用笔圈出了部分内容，并在那篇新闻分析报道旁边写了笔记。标题：“大思考的挑战，但细节甚少。”
--that I had says, "A Challenge to Think Big--". Well, just stop. You don't have to have the comma and "with Few Details." That makes it a negative. This type of speech was-- they never have details. They're not intended to have details. And it's like he couldn't help himself. He had to have that in there.
——我有一条说，“大思考的挑战——”。好吧，停。你不需要用逗号加“但细节甚少”。那让它变成了一个负面的。这类演讲是——他们从不提供细节。它们本就不是为了提供细节的。就像他情不自禁一样。他必须把那个加进去。
I should speak to this because, if we're looking to find common ground in our conversation, we just found it. It should've just said, "A Challenge to Think Big". It's the president's speech to a joint session and he deserves to have his moment and that would have been a fine headline. And what the article explained, whether there's details or not, it doesn't have to be in the headlines.
我应该谈谈这个，因为如果我们想在谈话中找到共同点，我们刚刚找到了。它应该只说“大思考的挑战”。这是总统在联席会议上的演讲，他理应拥有他的时刻，那会是一个很好的标题。而文章解释的内容，无论有没有细节，都不需要出现在标题里。
And then in the same article, sentence number two talks about-- first sentence, "President Donald Trump challenged the nation to think big Tuesday night, to set aside divisions and fend off terrorism, poverty, criminal, and unfair trade deals." Fair enough. I think that's great. But then he throws in a one-sentence paragraph. "But the divisions he's sown made his pleas for unity a hard sell in his first address to Congress," as if there were no division in the country. Everybody's happy and getting along. There was no division with Obama. But now Trump's come on the scene and he's sown division throughout the land. And I'm thinking, that's ridiculous. Donald Trump is a product of the division we have, but you're hanging it on him.
然后同一篇文章，第二句谈到——第一句，“唐纳德·特朗普总统周二晚挑战国家进行大思考，搁置分歧并抵御恐怖主义、贫困、刑事和不公平的贸易协议。”这很公平。我觉得那很棒。但随后他插入了一个单句段落。“但他播下的分歧使他向国会发表的首次演讲在团结呼吁上显得难以令人信服，”好像这个国家原本没有分歧。每个人都快乐且相处得很好。奥巴马时期没有分歧。但现在特朗普出现在现场，他已经在整个土地上播下了分歧。我想，那太荒谬了。唐纳德·特朗普是我们现有分歧的产物，但你却把它挂在他头上。
A product of the division? Or hasn't contributed at all to the division?
是分歧的产物？还是说他根本没有对分歧做出贡献？
I think he's contributed, definitely, but I also think he's a product of a division. But I don't think he started it.
我认为他绝对做出了贡献，但我也认为他是分歧的产物。但我不认为是他开始的。
That's a good criticism.
那是很好的批评。
There was less common ground when Mike Wilson, the editor, sat down with Mike Standish, the businessman who had said he was thinking of dropping his subscription to the paper. Standish's main advice was to remember that there are two sides to every story. Wilson felt like they were pretty careful to get both sides to every story. Half of your potential customers are probably conservatives, Standish said. As a business, you should keep that in mind. You need us as customers. I do, said Mike Wilson, the editor. But, he added.
当编辑迈克·威尔逊与商人迈克·斯坦迪什坐下来谈话时，共同点较少，就是那个说他在考虑取消报纸订阅的人。斯坦迪什的主要建议是记住每一个故事都有两面性。威尔逊觉得他们在每一个故事的两面性上都非常谨慎。斯坦迪什说，你们潜在客户的一半可能是保守派。作为企业，你应该记住这一点。你需要我们作为客户。是的，编辑迈克·威尔逊说。但是，他补充道。
I cannot change the truth that's out there to tailor it to any advertiser or any reader. And you know, it's funny. We're in a business where, probably unlike you, we sometimes know that we're going to alienate our audience with an article. It's a strange business to be in, where you think, well, probably a lot of readers won't like hearing this, but that's what we have to tell them tomorrow.
我不能为了迎合任何广告商或读者而改变现有的事实。而且，这很有趣。我们处在一个与你可能不同的行业，我们有时知道我们的一篇文章会疏远我们的受众。这真是个奇怪的行业，你会想，嗯，可能很多读者不喜欢听到这个，但那正是我们明天必须告诉他们的。
I get that. I get that.
我明白了。我明白了。
I have to apologize here. I messed up the recording, so Mike Standish is a little hard to hear.
我得道歉。我弄乱了录音，所以迈克·斯坦迪什的话有点难听清。
But as you write it, always remember there's two points of view. And even when no one wants to hear it, try to shoot at both of them. Try to say, where's the other side to this?
但在你写作时，总是要记住有两个观点。即使没有人想听，也要试着两边都射击。试着说，这件事的另一面在哪里？
So Mike, as we sit here, are you a subscriber to the Dallas Morning News?
所以迈克，当我们坐在这里时，你是《达拉斯晨报》的订阅者吗？
I am right now.
我现在是。
You think you'll stay one a little while and see how it goes?
你认为你会留下来一段时间看看进展吗？
I'll probably decide over the next few weeks.
我可能会在未来几周内决定。
You know, what I really appreciated about your email back to me was you said, if we don't have these conversations then we're lost. That we need to be having these conversations.
你知道，对于你给我的回复邮件，我真正感激的是你说，如果我们不进行这些对话，那么我们就迷失了。我们需要进行这些对话。
Our country really needs this. We're so divided right now. It's awful. And I'm probably part of the problem.
我们的国家真的需要这个。我们现在太分裂了。太可怕了。而且我可能也是问题的一部分。
And that was it. The two-- for the moment-- newspaper subscribers went home. Mike Wilson said he was glad that they came in.
就是这样。这两位——目前为止——报纸订阅者回家了。迈克·威尔逊说他很高兴他们来了。
Yeah, I feel really good. I feel great.
是啊，我感觉真好。我感觉棒极了。
Why?
为什么？
Because I've been troubled by the extent to which readers have been saying kind of the same things-- the things that they were saying.
因为读者们一直在说类似的话——他们说的那些话——这让我很困扰。
But do you feel better now? Because you didn't convince them.
但你现在感觉好些了吗？因为你并没有说服他们。
Yeah, somehow I do feel better.
是啊，不知何故我确实感觉好些了。
That's the funny thing about talking stuff out. Even if no one changes their mind about anything, sometimes everyone still feels better. Maybe because you listen. Or maybe it just feels good to make your points.
这就是谈论事情的有趣之处。即使没有人改变对任何事情的看法，有时大家仍然会感觉好些。也许是因为你倾听了。或者也许只是表达你的观点让人感觉良好。
Maybe, having heard me out, they'll read stories and they'll hear my voice. They want me to hear theirs. They want me to read it like they do. Maybe they'll read the stories and sort of hear my voice in there and see my attempts to be fair-- our attempts to be fair.
也许，听了我的陈述，他们会阅读报道并听到我的声音。他们想让我听到他们的声音。他们想让我像他们一样阅读。也许他们会阅读这些报道，某种程度上在里面听到我的声音，并看到我试图变得公平——我们试图变得公平的努力。
The next day's paper did include that story about immigrants possibly being separated from their parents at the border. The headline in the print version was "US May Split Kids, Parents," but online, the headline was "Imagine Being a Migrant Mother Separated from Your Child." Mike, the editor, said he thought that was fair since most of the article was from the other side-- the perspective of the administration. Stace, the doctor, thought it was a little loaded, though.
第二天的报纸确实包含了那个关于移民可能在边境被与父母分离的故事。印刷版的标题是“美国可能拆散儿童与父母”，但在网上，标题是“想象一下作为一名移民母亲与你的孩子分离”。编辑迈克说他认为这是公平的，因为文章的大部分来自另一面——行政部门的视角。但医生斯塔斯认为它有点带偏见。
And Mike, the businessman, went further. "Pathetic," he wrote to me about the headline. "Meant to tug at heartstrings and to think how mean we are." His email wasn't all thorns, though. At the end, he asked me to forward it to Mike Wilson at the paper. He said the last couple of days, he thought the headlines had been pretty fair.
商人迈克走得更远。“可悲，”他写信给我评价那个标题。“意在牵动心弦，并让人觉得我们有多刻薄。”他的邮件并非全是荆棘。最后，他让我把它转发给报社的迈克·威尔逊。他说过去几天，他认为标题相当公平。
David Kestenbaum is a producer on our program. Coming up, what I'm really, actually, truly thinking about this week. Never mind any of the stuff we've talked about so far today, and no disrespect to that stuff. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的制作人。接下来，本周我真正、确实在思考的事情。不用管我们今天谈论的所有内容，我并非对那些内容不尊重。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时在一分钟内播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Ask a Grown-Up," stories of people seeking answers from other adults. We have arrived at Act Three of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“请教成年人”，讲述人们向其他成年人寻求答案的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Ask My Grown-Up Kid.
第三幕：请教我的成年孩子。
So we had this idea putting together today's program that it would be interesting to find some parent who had a question for their kid that they could only ask their kid now that the kid was grown. Maybe something that would've been hard to talk about during all the drama of taking care of them when they were younger. And we recorded a couple of these with different families. And the one that was the most interesting was this one.
所以我们在制作今天的节目时有个主意，寻找一些父母，他们有一个只有在孩子成年后才能问孩子的问题，这会很有趣。也许是一些在抚养他们年幼时那种戏剧性的过程中很难谈论的事情。我们与不同的家庭录制了几个。而最有趣的一个是这个。
This is weirdly-- I'm very nervous about this, Dad.
这真是奇怪地——我对此非常紧张，爸爸。
I am too to a degree.
我也是，在某种程度上。
This is Chris Gethard and his dad, Ken Gethard.
这是克里斯·格哈德和他的父亲，肯·格哈德。
Because you and I don't really like-- we have a really good relationship. We don't sit down and have personal conversations that often, though.
因为你和我不真的喜欢——我们关系确实很好。不过我们确实不经常坐下来进行私人的对话。
Chris has been on our show now and then. He's a comedian. And his father wanted to talk to Chris about Chris' depression. Chris has depression. He's talked about it on stage and in his podcast. Which makes his dad feel bad, partly because Chris is talking publicly about stuff that the two of them have never really discussed. Chris didn't reveal his depression to his parents until he was in his early 20s and had an incident where he nearly died. And then a friend more or less forced him to tell his family. And his dad had questions about all that.
克里斯时不时会上我们的节目。他是一名喜剧演员。他的父亲想和克里斯谈谈他的抑郁症。克里斯有抑郁症。他在舞台上和他的播客里谈论过。这让他父亲感觉很糟糕，部分原因是克里斯在公开谈论他们两人从未真正讨论过的事情。克里斯直到20岁出头经历了一次濒死事故后才向父母透露他的抑郁症。然后一个朋友或多或少强迫他告诉了他的家人。他爸爸对此有很多问题。
Chris came into the studio having no idea what his dad wanted to ask about. And they sat down and, I don't know. Maybe we should have expected this. His dad didn't just jump right in with the stuff that he wanted to talk about. That was too heavy.
克里斯走进演播室时完全不知道他爸爸想问什么。他们坐了下来，嗯，我不知道。也许我们早该料到。他爸爸并没有直接切入他想谈论的事情。那太沉重了。
Well, the first one's actually a question from Mom.
好吧，第一个实际上是妈妈的问题。
Oh, OK.
噢，好。
Do you pray?
你祈祷吗？
Ken asked Chris about pro wrestling. He asked about sports.
肯问克里斯关于职业摔跤的事。他问了关于体育的事。
Why are you such an NBA fan rather than a pro baseball fan?
为什么你是一个NBA球迷而不是职业棒球迷？
They talked about their old neighborhood in New Jersey. Ken told Chris how much he hates celebrity endorsements. Would Chris ever do a celebrity endorsement? Would Chris ever do a sex scene in a movie? A nude scene in a movie? This continued for an hour. And then finally.
他们谈论了他们在纽泽西的旧社区。肯告诉克里斯他有多讨厌名人代言。克里斯会做名人代言吗？克里斯会做电影里的性爱场景吗？电影里的裸露镜头？这种情况持续了一个小时。最后。
Hey, listen. There's a couple questions I definitely do want to hit, so let's go to them. I don't want to run out of time.
嘿，听着。有几个问题我一定要问，所以让我们谈谈它们吧。我不想时间不够了。
Sure.
当然。
And then Ken brought up Chris' depression. They wanted to know why Chris took so long to tell his parents about it.
然后肯提到了克里斯的抑郁症。他们想知道为什么克里斯花了这么久才告诉父母。
Well, you know, when you finally told Mom, and that was, what, towards the end of college?
嗯，你知道，当你最终告诉妈妈时，那是，什么，大学快结束时？
Yeah.
是的。
I guess that was?
我想那是？
Yeah, I think that was--
是的，我想那是——
Absolutely floored us. We had zero clue.
绝对让我们惊呆了。我们一点头绪都没有。
Yeah.
是的。
And on one hand, we're like, the guilt. We've got to help protect you. Why couldn't we see this? But on the other hand, it's like, why didn't he come to us? Even now you're like that, Chris. There was something on the web a couple of years ago. It was something-- this is what I look like on a bad day or when I'm feeling depressed.
一方面，我们想的是，愧疚感。我们得保护你。为什么我们看不出来？但另一方面，就像是，为什么他没有告诉我们？即便现在你还是那样，克里斯。几年前网上有东西。是——这就是我在糟糕的一天或感到抑郁时的样子。
Yeah.
是的。
And you said something to the effect, I'll tell my wife, I'll tell my brother, but I'll never let my parents see me like this.
你说了一些类似于，我会告诉妻子，告诉兄弟，但我永远不会让父母看到我这样的话。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was after we've known. Even now it's sticking out there.
那是我们在知道之后。即便现在它还在那里。
Yeah, I don't know why. I don't know. I guess it would make me feel like I was letting you guys down in some way or failing in some way. I don't know. I don't know.
是啊，我不知道为什么。我不知道。我想那会让我觉得我以某种方式让你们失望了，或者失败了。我不知道。我不知道。
Yeah, but Mom and I would be the first two there to help you and do whatever it took to protect you.
是啊，但我和妈妈会是前两个去帮你的人，竭尽全力保护你。
I know. I don't know why I've never been comfortable with you guys seeing me like that or knowing that side of me so well, but I just felt like it was a thing to hide. I don't know. I don't know why. I don't know why.
我知道。我不知道为什么我一直不习惯你们看到我那样或那么了解我的那一面，但我只是觉得那是一件需要隐藏的事情。我不知道。我不知道为什么。我不知道为什么。
Because you guys did-- as soon as I told you, it was like everyone went into this mode where I was so supported. And I had always assumed that if I ever told anybody about it I was going to be on my own, whereas when I kind of hit rock bottom and started talking to you guys about it, it was like instantaneously the safest I ever felt.
因为你们确实——我一告诉你们，就像每个人都进入了一种我受到极大支持的模式。我一直假设如果我告诉任何人这件事我就会独自一人，而当我触底反弹并开始和你们谈论时，那简直是我感觉最安全的时刻。
Well, I'm glad you felt that way, but I hope you understand where I'm coming from on this.
好吧，我很高兴你有那种感觉，但我希望你明白我的立场。
Yeah. No, I wish I talked to you guys about it sooner. I wish.
是的。不，我希望我能早点和你们谈这件事。我希望。
And you did a fantastic job of hiding it from Mom and I, which I'll have all amounts of guilt over till my dying day.
而且你出色地对我和妈妈隐藏了它，这让我直到死的那天都会有无尽的愧疚感。
No, you don't have to. You don't have to have any guilt over that. I mean, I was so good at hiding it. So good at hiding it. And I don't know why. I don't know why I never let you and Mom know about that. It's just not my instinct. My instinct is that that's going to worry you guys so much and you're going to have to sit around and then be scared about me, and I don't want you doing that. And I always figured maybe I could push through it or it would pass. Even I felt like maybe I'm just a moody kid.
不，你不必。你不必为此感到任何愧疚。我的意思是，我太擅长隐藏它了。太擅长隐藏它了。而且我不知道为什么。我不知道为什么我从没让你和妈妈知道。这不是我的本能。我的本能是那会让你担心很多，你们不得不坐在一起然后为我感到害怕，我不希望你们那样。我总觉得也许我可以挺过去，或者它会过去。即使我自己也觉得也许我只是个喜怒无常的孩子。
If you're feeling bad and you need help and stuff like that, Chris, I would like you to come to us at any point in time. But I'm not a professional. I don't know what to tell you. I don't know if I'm making sense. I want to be there, but I don't want to tell you something wrong, either.
如果你感觉糟糕，需要帮助之类的事情，克里斯，我希望你在任何时候都能来找我们。但我不是专业人士。我不知道该告诉你什么。我不知道我说的对不对。我想要去支持你，但我也不能告诉你不正确的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
That's always in the back of my head. It's like, oh, god, if he comes to me, you know--
这总是出现在我的脑海里。就像，噢，天哪，如果他来找我，你知道——
[SNICKERING]
[窃笑]
[LAUGHING] Am I going to tell him something and all of a sudden he's going to be worse?
[大笑] 我会不会告诉他什么，然后突然他变得更糟了？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm scared. I don't think I want you coming to me, Dad, I'm upset. I need you to talk to me. I wouldn't know what to say. That's what you have a professional for. Does that make sense anywhere there?
我很害怕。我不认为我想要你来找我，爸爸，我很心烦。我需要你和我谈谈。我不知道该说什么。这就是你有专业人士的原因。这在什么地方讲得通吗？
Yeah. No, because I know that. I know that's the truth. I know that's the truth. I know you're not the guy to talk about that. It's part of what made it very hard to say it. But it doesn't-- I think I let that fear make me not talk to you about it. Whereas what really happened is exactly what I should have known you would have done, which was, you're not the guy to talk about it, but you're certainly going to make sure that I find the person--
是的。不，因为我知道那个。我知道那是事实。我知道那是事实。我知道你不是那个能谈论这个问题的人。这是让说出来变得非常困难的一部分原因。但它并没有——我想我让恐惧使我没有和你谈论这件事。而真正发生的是我应该知道你会做的完全正确的事情，那就是，虽然你不是那个能谈论的人，但你肯定会确保我找到那个人——
I'm going to get you the right person.
我会给你找到对的人。
You're going to get me there. That's one of the things I regret the most. Like, you were never going to be the guy who I could come to and say, Dad, I'm really sad and I don't know why. You weren't going to know what to say. But I should have given a lot more credit to knowing you were going to run through a wall to get me where I needed to go.
你会带我到那里。这是我最后悔的事情之一。就像，你永远不会成为我可以来找并说，爸爸，我很伤心，我不知道为什么的人。你不会知道该说什么。但我应该给予更多的信用，因为我知道你会撞破南墙来带我到我需要去的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
Chris Gethard and his dad, Ken Gethard. Thanks to them for agreeing to have this conversation on tape. Chris, by the way, talks about his depression in a one-man show that's going to be on HBO in May.
克里斯·格哈德和他的父亲，肯·格哈德。谢谢他们同意在录音中进行这次对话。顺便说一下，克里斯在他的单人秀中谈论了他的抑郁症，该秀将于五月在HBO播出。
Act Four, Ask a Very Grown Woman.
第四幕：请教一位真正的成年女性。
A few days ago, my friend Mary Ahearn died. Mary was 89. For the last 10 years, I've talked to her nearly every day. She and I met in the dog park and we organized our lives to meet there at 10:00 each night, which took a little more organization for me than for her. She'd been retired for years. I had a job. I traveled for my job. She'd had many very old-fashioned New York City jobs. She was a telephone switchboard operator and then the switchboard supervisor at Altman's Department Store for years, when both Altman's and telephone switchboards existed. Lived on a pension from a union in a rent-controlled apartment.
几天前，我的朋友玛丽·阿亨去世了。玛丽89岁。在过去的10年里，我几乎每天都和她交谈。她和我在狗公园认识，我们安排我们的生活，每晚10点在那里见面，这对我来说比她花了更多组织工作。她退休很多年了。我有一份工作。我为工作出差。她做过许多老式的纽约市工作。她当过电话总机接线员，后来在Altman's百货公司做了多年的总机主管，那时Altman's和电话总机都还存在。靠着工会的退休金生活在一个租金管制的公寓里。
When I traveled and when her health eventually stopped her from going to the park, we'd talk on the phone every night. OK, this is a very personal thing to say on the radio, but my wife and I separated a few years ago. And so for years now, Mary has usually been the person who I talked to last before I'd go to sleep. That's not a part of your day you let just anybody into, but I've never had a friendship like my friendship with her, where you just check in every day.
当我出差，或者她的健康状况最终阻止她去公园时，我们每晚都会通话。好吧，在电台说这事很私人，但我和妻子几年前分居了。所以多年来，玛丽通常是我睡觉前最后一个交谈的人。这不是你生活中会随随便便让任何人进入的一部分，但我从未有过像我和她这样的友谊，那种你每天都会确认彼此安好的友谊。
Mary is the person who I would watch presidential debates and election results with. And so most nights, she and I would catch up on the news. And we would talk about my day. And then she and I would talk about what happened that day with her and with John, her developmentally disabled cousin, 73 years old, who she cared for and housed for over four decades. Mary cooked dinner for John every night. Pot roast and mashed potatoes kinds of dinners. Dinners she did not eat herself.
玛丽是我会一起观看总统辩论和选举结果的人。所以大多数晚上，她和我都会谈论新闻。我们会谈论我的一天。然后她和我谈论她和约翰——她73岁的发展障碍堂兄——那天发生的事情，她照顾并安置了他四十多年。玛丽每晚为约翰做晚餐。炖肉和土豆泥之类的晚餐。她自己不吃的晚餐。
John's conversation style was to walk into a room and make a bitter pronouncement on some subject, often something he saw on the news. In the last year, he's become convinced that there are bedbugs in his room. Or some kind of bugs. Something that is biting him in his sleep. And although there's nothing there-- really, there's just nothing at all; it's all in his head-- he got obsessed. And he would haul shirts and pillow cases into the dining room to show Mary, insisting that the little dots in the fabric are living creatures and not just like the design of the cloth.
约翰的谈话风格是走进一个房间，对某个主题发表尖酸的评论，通常是他从新闻里看到的。在过去的一年里，他变得确信他的房间里有臭虫。或者某种虫子。某种在他睡觉时咬他的东西。虽然那儿什么都没有——真的，什么都没有；这全在他脑子里——他变得着迷了。他会把衬衫和枕套拖到餐厅给玛丽看，坚持说织物上的小点点是活的生物，而不是布料的设计。
And for months, I'd been telling Mary like, this is a new turn for John. He was always incredibly bullheaded, but now he had crossed over into something new. This just seemed like delusion and seemed sad in this whole new way. And I just thought we should have the exterminator come in and put on a big show and pretend to spray for bed bugs and put John's mind at ease. And nobody in this world had more compassion for John than Mary, but somehow this bedbug thing was a bridge too far for her. She did not want to indulge him on this one. She felt like if she started spending money on that, what was going to be next? It just seemed like a slippery slope.
好几个月来，我一直告诉玛丽，这对于约翰来说是一个新的转折。他总是非常固执，但现在他跨越到了某种新东西上。这看起来就像妄想，而且以这种全新的方式显得令人悲伤。我只是认为我们应该叫除虫员过来，演一场大戏，假装喷洒臭虫药，让约翰安心。这个世界上没有人比玛丽对约翰更有同情心，但不知为何这臭虫的事对她来说太过分了。她不想在这件事上迁就他。她觉得如果她开始在那上面花钱，接下来会是什么？这看起来就像是滑坡效应。
So every night, I would hear the latest with John and the bedbugs and the various relatives. Maureen and her kids in Washington state. John's brother, Neil, who I've never met, but I know all about his years on the NYPD and his pension and what booze he likes, his recent surgery, his recovery from the surgery. I have relatives of my own-- lots of them-- I don't know as well as this man, Neil, who I've never met.
所以每晚，我都会听到约翰和臭虫以及各种亲戚的最新消息。华盛顿州的莫琳和她的孩子们。约翰的兄弟尼尔，我从未见过，但我知道他在纽约警察局的所有年份、他的退休金以及他喜欢什么酒，他最近的手术，他从手术中的恢复。我有我自己的亲戚——很多——但我并不像认识这个人——尼尔，我从未见过的人——那样了解他们。
Mary and I were good enough friends that we would bore each other, which you only get with your family and your closest friends who you spend so much time with. Some nights I would be aware that she was ushering me off the phone. She would say to me, you must be very tired, which I knew was the signal for she'd had enough of me for the night.
玛丽和我是足够好的朋友，我们会让彼此感到厌烦，这只有在你与家人和你花这么多时间相处的亲密朋友之间才会发生。有些晚上我会意识到她正在打发我挂电话。她会对我讲，你肯定很累了，我知道那是她对我失去耐心的信号。
Mary lived her whole life in one spot in apartments on the same two blocks of New York City. This is 9th Avenue between 20th and 22nd Street. She died two blocks from where she grew up. She saw the neighborhood change over the years from longshoremen who worked the Chelsea Piers to gay men in the 1970s-- the YMCA of the song YMCA is just a couple blocks over on 23rd Street-- to rich people today. She seemed to be constantly writing checks to help out various nieces and their kids who needed the help. John basically showed up at her door in the mid-'70s. Nobody else in the family would take him.
玛丽一生都住在纽约市同一两条街区上的公寓里。这是第9大道，在20街和22街之间。她去世的地方离她长大的地方只有两个街区。她看着邻里多年来的变化，从在切尔西码头工作的码头工人，到1970年代的同性恋男人——那首歌曲《YMCA》的YMCA就在23街上几个街区——到今天的富人。她似乎一直在开支票帮助各种需要帮助的侄女和她们的孩子。约翰基本上在70年代中期出现在她家门口。家里其他人都不愿带他。
Her friend Gene came and lived with her for years. Red was a homeless guy she took in when he got his life together. Now he's a nurse. Beau needed a place when gentrification knocked him out of one of the last cheap apartments in the neighborhood. Her cousin Tom stayed during a rough patch. Everybody knew Mary was a soft touch for strays needing a home. Dogs, cats, people.
她的朋友吉恩来和她住了多年。雷德是个无家可归的人，她在他在生活步入正轨时收留了他。现在他是名护士。博需要在士绅化将他赶出邻里最后一批廉价公寓之一时有个地方住。她的堂弟汤姆在困难时期住过。大家都知道玛丽是收留流浪者的“软柿子”。狗、猫、人。
She and I would do the New York Times crossword puzzle together. She had a dark sense of humor, was quick with a fatalistic joke. When we'd go to plays and movies, she was fine if it was a comedy but always preferred something sad. She said it was the Irish in her. Three years ago, I was invited to give a speech in Ireland and Mary went with me as my plus-one. Though her house is decorated with little Irish sayings and knickknacks, this was her first trip to the country, and we visited the church in Kinsale where her father was baptized in 1889, before he left for America.
她和我会在一起做《纽约时报》的填字游戏。她有幽默感，很快就能讲出宿命论式的笑话。当我们去剧院和电影院时，如果是喜剧她没问题，但总是更喜欢悲伤的。她说那是她骨子里的爱尔兰血统。三年前，我受邀在爱尔兰发表演讲，玛丽作为我的配偶出席。尽管她的房子装饰着爱尔兰小谚语和饰品，这是她第一次去那个国家，我们参观了金塞尔的教堂，她父亲1889年来美国前在那里受洗。
She was not somebody to turn to for relationship advice. She'd never been in love. As well as we knew each other, and as much as we talked, I could never bring myself to ask if she had ever kissed anybody-- boy, man, woman. I'm fairly sure the answer was no, and I didn't want to make her say it out loud. The only crush that she ever admitted to was a boy she knew back when she was a teenager and got tuberculosis and lived in a TB ward uptown. He was smart, soft-spoken. And if I remember right, he also had TB, though he didn't survive it.
她不是一个适合寻求恋爱建议的人。她从未恋爱过。就像我们认识得那么好，就像我们谈论得那么多，我一直无法问她是否亲吻过任何人——男孩、男人、女人。我相当确定答案是否定的，我不想让她大声说出来。她唯一承认过的暗恋是她十几岁时认识的一个男孩，当时她患了结核病，住在上城的结核病房里。他很聪明，说话轻声细语。如果我记得没错，他也得了结核病，但他没有挺过来。
So she knew about as much about being in a marriage as I knew about running a 1950s-era telephone switchboard, which meant that if I had a bad day with my wife, Anaheed, and that's all I was thinking about, Mary was not a helpful person to talk to at all. For one thing, she was entirely and uncritically on my side in any dispute. Even disputes where I knew I was in the wrong and I told her I was in the wrong, she would come back time and again to a kind of Depression era view of marriage as a kind of practical arrangement that was not necessarily about happiness.
所以她对婚姻的了解就像我了解如何操作1950年代的电话总机一样多，这意味着如果我和妻子阿娜希德度过了糟糕的一天，而我只想着那件事，玛丽根本不是一个能提供帮助的人。首先，在任何争论中，她都完全、无条件地站在我这一边。即使是我知道自己有错并告诉她我错了的争论，她也会一次又一次地回到那种大萧条时代对婚姻的看法，认为婚姻是一种实践性安排，并不一定关乎幸福。
In her view, I was making most of the money in the family. Anaheed was comfortable, living in a nice apartment, could buy stuff she wanted. Why would Anaheed complain? Why wasn't she grateful? She had it so easy. I would try to explain to her the things that I was doing that rightly disappointed Anaheed. Mary would shake her head. I don't see what she has to complain about.
在她看来，我赚了家里大部分钱。阿娜希德很舒服，住在一间不错的公寓里，可以买她想要的东西。阿娜希德为什么抱怨？她为什么不感恩？她过得太容易了。我试着向她解释我做的事情，这些事情正确地让阿娜希德失望了。玛丽会摇摇头。我不明白她有什么可抱怨的。
Today's radio show is about asking a grown-up for advice. I am fully grown up. And I'm older than I sound on the radio. I just turned 58. That's basically 60. That's old enough that, last week, when I read something by somebody in their 30s who said, well, of course nobody ever fully feels like a grown-up, I wanted to say, no, I actually feel like a grown-up. I feel like a grown-up. I feel my responsibilities. I feel the weight of them. I know when I have lived up to my own ideals for how I want to be in the world and treat others around me, and when I haven't, I feel it. I feel tired in this way that I definitely did not when I was younger.
今天的广播节目是关于向成年人寻求建议的。我已经完全是个成年人了。我比电台听起来要老。我刚满58岁。那基本就是60岁了。这岁数大到上周当我读到某位30多岁的人说，嗯，当然没有人能完全感觉像个成年人时，我想说，不，我实际上感觉自己像个成年人。我感觉自己像个成年人。我感受到了我的责任。我感受到了它们的重量。我知道什么时候我活出了自己想要的为人处世的理想，什么时候我没有，我感觉到了。我感到了一种我年轻时绝对没有的疲惫。
And I'm talking about Mary here on the radio right now because, frankly, it's hard for me to think or talk about anything else this week, but also because this week's theme about asking advice from a grown-up. When you get to a certain age, you realize each grown-up is good for advice but on certain subjects and not on other subjects, and you have to be picky and choose the right grown-up for the right subjects. And then, I think I'm learning this week, when you get to a certain age, there aren't many grown-ups older than you to ask advice from. The ones you love die off.
我在这里电台谈论玛丽，因为，坦白讲，本周我很难思考或谈论任何其他事情，但也因为本周关于向成年人征求建议的主题。当你到了某个年龄，你意识到每个成年人都适合在特定主题上提供建议，而在其他主题上不行，你必须挑剔并为正确的主题选择正确的成年人。然后，我想我这周正在学习这一点，当你到了某个年龄，就没有多少比你更老的成年人可以征求建议了。你爱的那些人会死掉。
And then-- and this is a total unforeseen pisser-- you miss their crappy, bad advice. You really miss it. Because even the worst advice from a friend comes with a second message. And that's just I got your back. Mary gave me some really useless marriage advice, and I gave her completely unwanted and unheeded advice about her cousin's non-existent bedbugs. And we each ignored the other's advice. But we did heed the other message. She had my back. I had hers. Which in the end, of course, was more important, anyway.
然后——这是一个完全无法预见的糟心事——你会怀念他们糟糕的、坏建议。你真的会怀念它。因为即使是朋友提出的最糟糕的建议也带有第二个信息。那就是我支持你。玛丽给了我一些非常无用的婚姻建议，而我给了她完全不受欢迎且未被理会的关于她堂兄不存在的臭虫的建议。我们各自无视了对方的建议。但我们确实在意对方的信息。她支持我。我支持她。当然，这最终当然更重要。
[MUSIC - "SCOTLAND THE BRAVE"]
[音乐 - 《苏格兰勇士》]
Yes, I know it's incredibly corny to be playing this music right here at this spot, but this is Mary's cousin, Sean, playing for her in her apartment on St. Patty's Day a couple of years ago.
是的，我知道在这里播放这首音乐非常老套，但这是玛丽的堂兄肖恩，几年前在圣帕特里克节在她的公寓里为她演奏。
OK. Ready to go?
好了。准备好了吗？
I thought you were starting.
我还以为是你开始呢。
All right. I'll start. I'll start.
好吧。我来开始。我来开始。
Oh, hi.
噢，嗨。
Hi. I'm Ira Glass.
嗨。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
I'm Mary, Ira's friend.
我是玛丽，艾拉的朋友。
This is Mary recorded a couple years ago when she and I shot a video explaining to older listeners how to download a podcast, which Mary knew how to do.
这是玛丽几年前录制的，当时她和我拍摄了一段视频，向老年听众解释如何下载播客，玛丽知道怎么做。
I don't need to give away your age, but is it safe to say you are an actual older person?
我不需要透露你的年龄，但可以肯定说你是一位真正的老年人吗？
I'm on the dark side of 85. How's that?
我处于85岁的后半段。那样行吗？
OK. [LAUGHING]
OK。[大笑]
[LAUGHING]
[大笑]
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivas, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Music help today from Damien Graef.
我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·傅制作。我们的工作人员包括爱丽丝·伯格森、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇瓦斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、金伯利·亨德森、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆、塞斯·林德、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。今天的音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, whenever he acts weird or says stuff like this, I have to remember he was homeschooled.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，每当他表现得很奇怪或说类似这样的话时，我不得不提醒自己他是居家教育长大的。
Oh, my god, why does it sound like I grew up in a box where I wasn't allowed to ever have contact with another boy or something?
噢，天哪，为什么听起来我好像是在一个盒子里长大的，在那儿我不被允许和任何其他男孩接触似的？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Wonderful. Wonderful.
太棒了。太棒了。
Isn't that great?
那不是很棒吗？